ein industriekomplex mit explosiver
vergangenheit heute längst vergessen
die runden zylinder mit den verstärkten
rippen an der außenseite waren hoch
spezialisiert
das ist das falsche
mächtige küsten befestigungen in ghana
erinnern an den grausamen handel mit
sklaven
betrachtet man das ausmaß und die solide
bauweise dieser befestigungen stellt
sich die frage wieso gerade hier was war
hier so wertvoll
ein unterirdischer atombunker in florida
in dem riesigen höhlenartigen raum als
ort jeder schritt ein echo da war
definitiv etwas wichtiges untergebracht
und ein verfallener gigant einst das
zentrum der industriellen revolution in
serbien
ursprünglich war das ein hoffnungsvolles
symbol für die zukunft des landes aber
dann spielte das gelände eine völlig
unerwartete rolle
[Musik]
zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
vergangener zeit einst mühsam erschaffen
heute nur noch schatten ihrer selbst
zeit ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
auf einem riesigen areal versteckt in
den wäldern west polens befindet sich
eine seltsame gruppe von gebäuden
anfangs glaubt man durch einen ganz
normalen wald zu laufen aber dann
entdeckt man spuren der zivilisation
erst reste von eisenbahnschienen und
kleinere bauten dann immer mehr und
plötzlich dieser monumentalen
konstruktionen die sind überall
[Musik]
beton riesen wie aus einem science
fiction film
sie wirken fast so als hätten sie beine
und könnten jeden moment loslaufen
sie sehen sehr solide aus allerdings
sind sie nach oben hin offen für die
elemente das dach fehlt eine
eigenwillige konstruktion
dann schaut mal um die ecke und findet
ein weiteres rechteckiges gebäude
die anlage ist so verfallen dass sich
ihr ursprünglicher sinn gar nicht mehr
erschließt es muss etwas industrielles
gewesen sein aber was
tiefer im wald gibt es noch mehr zu
entdecken
da sind große offenen becken die
irgendwie verhext scheinen sie sind mit
kanälen und rohren verbunden nicht nur
über sondern auch unterirdisch
offenbar waren sie teil einer
weitläufigen industrieanlage mitten im
nirgendwo
dieser gebäudekomplex gehört eigentlich
nicht in den wald sondern in eine stadt
irgend etwas spezielles ging hier vor
und jemand betrieb immensen aufwand um
dieses unternehmen geheim zu halten
die bahngleise lassen erahnen wie
wichtig dieser ort einmal gewesen sein
muss
die anlage erstreckt sich über ein
riesiges areal
mit überwucherten gleisen und diversen
bauten die auf den ersten blick zwischen
den vielen bäumen kaum zu erkennen sind
das war auf jeden fall eine große sache
die bahnstrecke ende dort das heißt
etwas wurde dorthin gebracht oder
abtransportiert
aber was
radoslav dunkel ist historiker an der
nahe gelegenen universität jena gotha
seit vielen jahren ist er den
geheimnissen des geländes auf der spur
[Musik]
mit hilfe dieser rampe wurde die kohle
für das kraftwerk angeliefert die ganze
anlage wurde mit kohle betrieben
ein blick auf das ganze genügt um zu
erkennen dass dort große mengen kohle
durchliefen
was auch immer produziert wurde fraas
jede menge energie
[Musik]
die eisenbahn beliefert aber nicht nur
das kraftwerk die bauwerke am anderen
ende des areals verraten worum es dort
ging
von außen betrachtet lässt sich die
funktion der anlage kaum erkennen da
muss man sich schon gut mit der technik
auskennen für die meisten polen selbst
die aus der näheren umgebung ist dieser
ort geheimnisumwoben
sie wissen nicht wie bedeutend er war
und wie gefährlich
das ungewöhnliche design dient einem
brisanten zweck
was wir hier sehen sind sie los darin
lagerte hoch gefährliches material
deshalb ist die bauweise so massiv und
monumental bei einer explosion wäre die
druckwelle nach oben geschossen
so hätte es in der umgebung wenige opfer
gegeben
die rätselhafte anlage ist eine
sprengstoff fabrik mit diesem koloss im
zentrum
[Musik]
das sind keine kleinen speicher diese
silos sind unvorstellbar groß kaum
auszudenken dass sie bis zum rand mit
sprengstoff gefüllt waren
schon ein funke könnte alles zum
explodieren bringen deshalb hätten die
erbauer entsprechende
sicherheitsvorkehrungen
selbstverständlich hat die sprengstoff
produktion ihre risiken deshalb ist es
nur logisch eine munitionsfabrik weit
weg von der nächsten stadt zu bauen und
nicht nur das auch die einzelnen fabrik
bereichen liegen weit auseinander die
benötigten chemikalien sind sehr
reaktionsfreudig sie sind quasi dafür
gemacht in die luft zu gehen im
rohzustand sind sie nur schwer zu
kontrollieren
deshalb durfte beim transport nichts
schiefgehen die bahnstrecke sollte eine
reibungslose anlieferung gewährleisten
wer produziert die hier munition und
sprengstoff in großem stil tief in den
wäldern west polens
und warum war das unternehmen streng
geheim
die spur führt zurück in die zeit des
zweiten weltkriegs
hitler hatte sehr ehrgeizige pläne für
das deutsche reich
er wollte gewaltige mengen munition und
sprengstoff herstellen
der einmarsch in polen war auch so etwas
wie der startschuss für den aufbau einer
neuen industrie region
vor diesem hintergrund entsteht die
munitionsfabrik im damaligen christian
stadt heute nur wo grootbos jansky
ursprünglich gehört sie zur dynamit
nobel ag gegründet von keinem geringeren
als dynamit erfinder alfred nobel zu
spitzenzeiten produziert das werk weit
über 1000 tonnen sprengstoff im monat
der ängstigen was da alles hergestellt
wurde es gibt hinweise dass hexogen
dabei war das ist noch explosiver als
tnt dieses zeug macht ordentlich
begonnen und die silos waren voll davon
vermutlich produzierten die deutschen
dort auch nitroglyzerin eine der
exklusivsten chemikalien überhaupt
das kenne ich nur in kleinen ampullen
aber nicht in großen bottichen
die größte munitionsfabrik im dritten
reich in ihrem heilen schuften männer
und frauen unter schwersten bedingungen
der munition herzustellen ist gefährlich
doch statt ausgebildete profis mit viel
erfahrung setzten die deutschen
zwangsarbeiter kriegsgefangene
waffen herstellen die dann womöglich
gegen ihre eigenen landsleute zum
einsatz kamen
für die zwangsarbeiter ist das leben
nahezu unerträglich
die bedingungen waren furchtbar die
arbeit war gefährlich und extrem
gesundheitsschädlich die aufseher und
werte in den umliegenden lagern waren
grausam zu dem gefangenen ob durch
krankheit oder das brutale naziregime im
grunde schwebten sie ständig in
lebensgefahr
wer versuchte zu fliehen wurde auf der
stelle erschossen und durch einen
anderen zwangsarbeiter ersetzt
hitlers architekten haben die anlage auf
maximale effizienz getrimmt doch an
einem tag im jahr 1944 geht etwas
furchtbar schief
es gibt kaum noch historische unterlagen
aber wir wissen dass es eine riesige
detonation gaben in kriegszeiten denkt
man natürlich sofort an sabotage
falls es sabotage ist wer könnte
dahinter stecken
[Musik]
es geschah am frühen morgen bevor die
arbeiter anfingen die explosion traf
einige hauptgebäude wir wissen bis heute
nicht was genau passiert ist aber wenn
man bedenkt dass dort zwangsarbeiter
schafft hätten und dass der polnische
widerstand in der region aktiv war dann
muss man nur eins und eins
zusammenzählen es kann durchaus sabotage
gewesen sein mit dem ziel die
waffenproduktion zu zerstören
aus zeitzeugenberichten geht hervor dass
1944 und 45 mindestens drei explosionen
schwere schäden in kristianstad
anrichten als
ihre kriegsniederlage absehbar ist
zerstören die deutschen nahezu alle
unterlagen aus der munitionsfabrik
was sich noch verwerten lässt nehmen die
vorstoßenden russischen streitkräfte mit
nach dem krieg werden die bauten dem
verfall überlassen
heute ist die weitläufige anlage ein
öffentlicher park aber nur wenige
besucher kennen seine dunkle geschichte
ich bin da gespalten
einerseits bewundere ich die technische
leistung und die größe der vertrieb
andererseits war mein großvater während
des zweiten weltkriegs ein
kriegsgefangener der deutschen und das
macht mich betroffen
ist die menschen mussten hier unter
unwürdigen bedingungen arbeiten die sie
krank machten wie getrennt von ihren
familien
[Musik]
unter einem erdhügel nahe der ostküste
floridas liegt ein längst vergessenes
relikt
[Musik]
marx in einem wäldchen direkt neben der
autobahn steht eine abgestufte weiße
mauern mit einer schlichten weißen tür
dahinter muss ich doch etwas
interessantes verbergen
oberhalb der betonmauer findet man
mehrere lüftungsschächte die nach unten
führen irgendetwas besonderes muster
verborgen gewesen sein aber äußerlich
deutet nichts darauf hin was das war
stahltüren gelangt man in eine
sicherheitszone eine art
dekontaminierung traum was auch immer
dort vorging war offenbar sehr
gefährlich
was war der sinn dieser eigenartigen
anlage und warum liegt sie tief unter
der erde versteckt
wirklich seltsam all diese stahlträger
die groß genug wären um ein hochhaus
oder ein stadion zu tragen aber darüber
ist bloß ein gras bewachsene hügel
sicherheitsvorkehrungen und eine massive
bauweise schützen das was sich im
inneren der anlage befindet
in dem riesigen höhlenartigen raum
erzeugt jeder schritt ein echo da war
definitiv etwas wichtiges untergebracht
was war hier verborgen und vor wem
die anlage liegt ganz in der nähe des
kennedy space center sie stammt aus der
zeit des ost west konflikt als
sowjetunion und usa sich den sogenannten
wettlauf ins all liefern
der bunker wurde 1967 errichtet auf dem
höhepunkt des kalten krieges er liegt
unweit von kuba das damals unter dem
verdacht stand atomwaffen zu lagern
während der kubakrise 62 war der
konflikt um die stationierung russischer
nuklearwaffen auf der insel beinahe
eskaliert
interessant an diesem bunker ist seine
ausrichtung schaut man sich die umgebung
an wird deutlich dass der eingang dem
kennedy space center abgewandt ist
warum ist das so im fall eines angriffs
wäre vermutlich das weltraumzentrum das
ziel gewesen
die ausrichtung in die entgegengesetzte
richtung bot also zusätzlichen schutz
[Musik]
doch damit nicht genug die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen setzten damals
neue maßstäbe
marc oxley kennt die geschichte der
anlage
das ist kein gewöhnlicher
atomschutzbunker das ist etwas anderes
die äußeren wände sind 45 zentimeter
stark einige der innenwände sogar über
einen meter
das fundament ist fast drei meter dick
diese massiven stahlträger deuten auf
eine spitze nutzen
[Musik]
hier sehen sie dass dies eigentlich ein
kommunikations bunker war betrieben von
l t and i und vom
verteidigungsministerium
ziel war es die leitungen für
militärische ferngespräche im fall eines
nuklear kriegs aufrecht zu erhalten
die us behörden fürchten dass die
telefonleitungen nach einem atomschlag
unter dem ansturm der zivilbevölkerung
zusammenbrechen würden für die
militärische kommunikation richten sie
deshalb ein parallelsystem 1 das so
genannte automatic boys network kurz
die order von leitungen liefen parallel
zum normalen telefon betrieb
so konnten die behörden im krisenfall
die kommunikation zwischen den
verteidigungs behörden und militärischen
einrichtungen aufrechterhalten
zu dem umfangreichen projekt gehören
unzählige bunker wie dieser
diese einrichtungen waren im abstand von
100 bis 200 kilometern über die gesamten
usa verteilt
tnt baute drei verschiedene bunker typen
typ 1 war voll mit kommunikations
equipment typ 2 diente zur
stromerzeugung und typ 3 war mit
mikrowellen technik ausgestattet
mikrowellen verbindungen ermöglichen
eine drahtlose kommunikation das kann im
kriegsfall enorm wichtig sein
eine atomare explosion würde im ganzen
land unvorstellbare zerstörung anrichten
die detonation könnte dem bunker zwar
nicht viel anhaben doch der damit
einhergehende elektromagnetischen impuls
würde sämtliche technik in einem großen
radius außer gefecht setzen was also
wäre im fall eines atomangriffs in der
anlage passiert
der bunker ist eine art stahlkäfig wenn
eine atombombe in der atmosphäre
explodiert sendet sie einen elektrischen
impuls aus der in einem umkreis von
mehreren hundert kilometern sämtliche
elektronik zerstört
um sensible geräte zu schützen muss man
sie in einen faradayschen käfig legen
und genau das hat man hier gemacht
ein faradayscher käfig kann aus
einfachem kaninchendraht bestehen
er schirmt sein inneres gegen die
elektrische ladung ab
so waren alle geräte und auch die
menschen im bunker vor dem geschützt was
sich draußen abspielt
nur die kommunikationsausrüstung zu
schützen reicht nicht aus denn im
schlimmsten fall wäre niemand mehr darum
sie zu bedienen
deshalb werden vorkehrungen für die zeit
nach einem atomschlag getroffen
es gab dosen mit butter pulver ein
pulver spaghetti bolognese soße alles
mögliche genug damit fünf personen 30
tage lang überleben konnten
[Musik]
die besatzung wurde den bunker im
ernstfall nicht verlassen er bleibe so
lange verschlossen bis die meldung käme
dass es draußen sicher wäre
[Musik]
das ist einer von mehreren strahlungs
detektoren sie sind überall um die
anlage herum angebracht nach einem
angriff sollten sie die gamma strahlung
messen und die werte an eine
überwachungsstation senden
von dort aus würden dann die schutztüren
geschlossen und die kohlenstoff
luftfilter systeme eingeschaltet so
bliebe die luftqualität in der anlage
erhalten
sobald die türen geschlossen werden
würden die zugänge strengstens
kontrolliert
[Musik]
wenn sie nach einem radioaktiven
ereignis vor diesen massiven mit gleich
verkleideten türen stünden hätten sie
einen dekontaminierung sun tzu kann und
würden zunächst in die sogenannte
dekontamination dusche gehen
dort würden sie alle radioaktiven
partikel abspülen damit diese nicht in
die anlage gelangen
nur so könnte man das überleben der
mitarbeiter sicherstellen
jahre lang halten sich die mitarbeiter
bereit für den atomaren ernstfall
der glücklicherweise niemals eintritt
das muss man sich mal vorstellen
sie saßen in diesen bunkern und warteten
auf einen atomkrieg von dem sie hofften
dass er nie kommen würde aber wenn er
käme müssten sie sich fragen ob ihre
familien und freunde ausgelöscht worden
waren und gleichzeitig müssten sie
diesen schwierigen job machen
nach einem angriff sollten sie einen
monat lang da drin bleiben
dieses schicksal bleibt den mitarbeitern
am ende jedoch erspart anfang der 90er
jahre löst ein neues militärisches
kommunikationsnetz autobahn ab und das
us militär gibt die alten anlagen auf
heute findet der ort eine ganz andere
verwendung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
inzwischen ist alles internetbasiert das
internet der dinge ist überall jeder hat
ein smartphone und nutzt gps navigation
riesige datenmengen erfordern was ich
strom und prozessoren und da kommt ein
rechenzentrum wie dieses ins spiel
schon bald wird der bunker einen neuen
zweck erfüllen
in seinem inneren sollen riesige server
stehen
dort sind die geräte verein griffen und
möglichen klimakatastrophen geschützt
nach und nach sollen weitere bunker
umfunktioniert werden
[Musik]
dieses prinzip findet heute überall auf
der welt nachahmer wie die usa wollen
auch andere länder ihre systeme vor
allem schützen was sie zerstören und
somit die sicherheit des staates
gefährden könnte
[Musik]
an der küste von ghana erstreckt sich
eine reihe eindrucksvoller bauten
[Musik]
sie sind riesig direkt an den klippen
fast wie paläste mit kunstvollen treppen
terrassen und bogengängen sehr
beeindruckend
entlang der küste stehen mehrere solcher
anlagen einige sind ziemlich verfallen
andere gut erhalten sie wurden gebaut um
zu überdauern
aus der nähe betrachtet wird
offensichtlich dass sie zur verteidigung
dienten wegen der lage und vor allem
wegen der kanonen mit ihrer feuerkraft
hinter den imposanten mauern verbirgt
sich um erwartete und
je weiter man hinein kommt desto mehr
entdeckt man unter der oberfläche liegt
eine versteckte welt die dunkelheit
verschlingt alles die luft ist dick und
schwer überall feuchtigkeit und verfall
an den wänden hängen ketten dicke
stahltüren verschließen winzige zellen
ein seltsamer ort der kontrast zwischen
oben und unten ist gewaltig oben
herrscht opulenz das gefühl von weite
und licht man hat blick auf die küste
und den ozean und unter der erde liegt
ein verlies
wozu wurden die bauten errichtet
die antwort führt zurück in eine zeit
aggressiver europäische
expansionspolitik
im fünfzehnten jahrhundert landen
handelsschiffe an der küste ghanas
sie sollen den lauf der geschichte
westafrikas für immer verändern
die weißen force zeugen bis heute davon
zuerst kann die portugiesen sie hatten
genug wissen und erfahrung um
handelsrouten nach afrika und asien
aufzubauen
die seefahrer waren auf der suche nach
rohstoffen
doch was sie fanden überstieg ihre
kühnsten träume
die akan völker an der westküste afrikas
besaßen eine menge gold sie waren bereit
es gegen unedle metalle textilien und
andere waren einzutauschen
der küstenabschnitt wird so wertvoll
dass die portugiesen ihn die medien
die engländer sprechen etwas poetischer
von der goldküste
die portugiesen wollten das gold um
jeden preis für sich haben um es zu
verteidigen bauten sie die force
dies sind die historischen force von
ghana
eine reihe mächtiger befestigungsanlagen
erbaut von europäischen kolonialmächten
nx kingsley ob er kennt ihre geschichte
wir sind hier in niederkassel einer der
ältesten europäischen anlagen an der
afrikanischen westküste
sie wurde 1482 von den portugiesen
erbaut das baumaterial stammte aus
portugal und holland schauen sie mal
witzig die mauern sind sie konnten jedem
angriff widerstehen
die festungen sollten einschüchtern vier
außen türme dienten als batterien
kanonen entlang der außenseiten hohe
mauern die sich aus den felsen empor
hoben
das war ein riesiger aufwand aber
notwendig um andere kolonialherren
fernzuhalten und sicherzustellen dass
die einheimischen ihr gold nur den
vertretern der portugiesischen krone
überließen
dies vor die fonds erfüllten ihren zweck
aus aufzeichnungen wissen wir dass die
portugiesen bis 1550 jedes jahr bis zu
12.000 400 unzen gold erbeuteten das war
ein ansehnlicher teil der gesamtmenge
die damals nach europa kam
aber im laufe der jahre melden auch
andere europäer ambitionen an
sie haben es ebenfalls auf ghanas
bodenschätze abgesehen
die niederlande spanien england
frankreich alle begehrten die reichtümer
der goldküste und sie waren bereit mit
allen mitteln um einen teil vom kuchen
zu kämpfen
im 17 jahrhundert konnten die
portugiesen ihnen schließlich nichts
mehr entgegensetzen ihre vorherrschaft
änderte der markt stand nun allen
kolonialmächten offen
jede nation baute befestigungen um sich
ein areal zu sichern
insgesamt gab es etwa 40 force auf einer
500 kilometer langen strecke entlang der
küste mit
der zeit ändern sich die güter die dort
gehandelt werden
bald ist ein neuer rohstoff heiß begehrt
seinen ursprung hat er auf den
karibischen inseln
zucker war extrem gefragt und sehr
lukrativ die europäer konnten nicht
genug davon kriegen
allerdings war die produktion sehr
aufwendig man brauchte viele
zuverlässiger arbeiter
und die waren mangelware im nord- und
mittelamerika die indigenen ureinwohner
waren stark dezimiert und selbst die
ärmsten europäer wollten die teure
überfahrt und die furchtbaren
arbeitsbedingungen nicht auf sich nehmen
für den mickrigen hungerlohn den sie auf
den plantagen bekommen hätten
in den augen der europäer gibt es jedoch
genug billiger arbeitskräfte in
westafrika auf den handel mit gold folgt
der grausame handel mit menschen
klagen zu verkaufen die bei der
produktion von rohstoffen eingesetzt
wurden entwickelte sich zu einem
gewinnbringenden geschäft
[Musik]
die europäer betrachteten die menschen
an der afrikanischen westküste als im
überfluss verfügbare arbeitskräfte
sie haben sie gewissenlos ausgebeutet
weil der profit stimmte
afrika war politisch instabil und genau
das nutzen die europäer aus sie
verfrachteten die sklaven nach amerika
eine zentrale rolle spielen dabei die
force
sind wir im berüchtigten cape coast
castle
es wurde 1664 von den briten gebaut
während der zeit des sklavenhandels
in den kerkern lebten bis zu 1000
sklaven unter schrecklichen bedingungen
dicht gedrängt wie sardinen kaum luft
zum atmen wenig wasser keine ärztliche
versorgung
sie schliefen auf dem boden und wo sie
schliefen da aßen und entleerten sie
sich auch
die bedingungen waren furchtbar ein
hoher prozentsatz der sklaven starb
schon vor der überfahrt nach amerika
männer und frauen werden voneinander
getrennt manche frauen erleiden ein
besonders tragisches schicksal
das war der frauen kerker zwei bis
dreihundert junge frauen wurden hier
gefangen gehalten sie wurden regelmäßig
aufgeholt vergewaltigt und wieder
runtergebracht diese armen frauen wurden
zu sexsklavinnen degradiert sie mussten
das alles still erdulden denn sie hatten
praktisch keine chance sich zu wehren
alles war ihnen genommen worden und es
gab niemanden der ihnen hätte helfen
können
wie viele force an der goldküste ist
cape coast castle ein ort der
widersprüche
nur wenige meter von den kerkern
entfernt waren lichtdurchflutete räume
mit parkettböden vornehmen möbeln und
wunderschöne aussicht dort lebten die
gewinner des sklavenhandels
eine grauenvolle vorstellung dass diese
leute sich da richtig gut gehen ließen
während sich nur wenige meter entfernt
unbeschreibliches menschliches leid
abspielte
welches schicksal erwartet all jene die
unter den furchtbaren zuständen in den
fonds leiden
in gut 300 jahren werden schätzungsweise
zwölf einhalb millionen afrikaner wifi
in die neue welt verschifft
hier war der letzte sammelpunkt für die
sklaven wer bis hierhin überlebt hatte
ging durch diese tür egal ob mann oder
frau man nannte sie die tür ohne
wiederkehr
draußen lag ein schiff das die menschen
nach nordamerika oder in die karibik
brachte
das war ein schauplatz eines der
schlimmsten verbrechen in der geschichte
der menschheit
unvorstellbar grausam und es dauerte bis
ins neunzehnte jahrhundert an das ist
gar nicht so lange her
das unmenschliche geschäft der sklaverei
endet 1869
aber erst als das britische empire im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert mit der die
kolonisation beginnt werden die force
den einheimischen übergeben
[Musik]
lange bleibt der sklavenhandel ein
tabuthema in ghana
inzwischen wird die schmerzliche
geschichte aufgearbeitet mehr als zwei
drittel der besucher in den fonds sind
ghana
[Musik]
das ist ein relikt mit großer bedeutung
die fonds sind wichtig weil sie die
menschen daran erinnern was sich hier
abgespielt hat und wie abscheulich
menschen zueinander sein können
[Musik]
in belgrad steht ein verfallenes bauwerk
mit dem einst ein neues kapitel der
serbischen geschichte begann
[Musik]
dieser ort hat offensichtlich eine menge
mitgemacht er ist total zerstört
die stufen sie ihn aus als würden sie
unter dem gewicht des nächsten besuchers
zusammenbrechen das ganze gebäude kann
jeden moment einstürzen
nach und nach holt sich die natur den
ort zurück die vögel nisten dort bäume
wachsen aus den wänden die erde scheint
das gelände zu verschlingen
ein kräftiger sturm könnte
wahrscheinlich eine zerstörerische
kettenreaktion auslösen eigentlich ein
wunder dass es noch steht
der ort hat definitiv eine geschichte zu
erzählen aber die liegt verborgen unter
haufenweise müll sogar ein boot hat sich
dorthin verirrt
drum herum sind weitere gebäude zu den
schienen führen
das ganze ist offenbar ein weitläufiger
industriekomplex
einst symbolisierte dieser ort in beginn
einer neuen fortschrittlichen er aber
die ruine von heute erzählt eine andere
geschichte
dort hat der krieg seine spuren
hinterlassen
gravierende spuren
die fabrik stand ursprünglich für einen
neubeginn für aufkeimende hoffnung aber
was dann passierte war eine schreckliche
tragödie
[Musik]
begraben unter schutt liegen die
ursprünge eines bedeutenden moments in
der jüngeren geschichte serbiens
seit dem 15 jahrhundert hatte serbien
zum osmanischen reich gehört
1878 wurde es schließlich unabhängig
unter der herrschaft des osmanischen
reichs war serbien eine art sklaven
start gewesen aber dann lösten sich die
fesseln und der fortschritt konnte
einzug halten
bauwerke wie dieses sind das ergebnis
und ein vorzeichen für die dinge die da
kommen sollen als serbien zu einem
unabhängigen königreich wurde war es an
einem bescheidenen zustand es gab wenige
große städte kaum infrastruktur und
industrie
der serbische könig milan der erste
heißt ausländische investoren willkommen
er hat große pläne für sein land
diese fabrik hat beim übergang von der
landwirtschaft zu industrie eine
zentrale rolle gespielt
dies ist die belgrader zucker raffinerie
ammann baute dort zuckerrüben an und
verarbeitete sie zucker sollte der
treibstoff für die industrielle
revolution werden für den einheimischen
experten juristisch war es der aufbruch
zu einem neuen belgrad
für die stadt war der komplex von
größter bedeutung
tausende arbeitsplätze wurden geschaffen
das brachte viel veränderung mit sich
und führte zur ansiedlung weiterer
unternehmen
man kann es sich richtig vorstellen der
lärm der maschinen das gedränge der
arbeiter für alle beteiligten muss es
eine aufregende zeit gewesen sein
alles ist auf expansion angelegt immer
mehr arbeiter sollen in die stadt ziehen
aber gleich zu beginn gibt es die ersten
probleme
nach wenigen jahren ging das unternehmen
pleite
sie baten die regierung um hilfe und
seitdem war die raffinerie ein
staatlicher betrieb
aber das ist nicht alles die arbeiter
fordern mehr rechte und besseren
bedingungen das führt zu blutigen
auseinandersetzungen vor den fabriktoren
die industrialisierung brachte enorme
veränderungen mit sich und das in einem
rasanten tempo
eben war da noch eine agrargesellschaft
und plötzlich wurde sie zur
industriegesellschaft
kürzlich diktierte die uhr die
arbeitszeiten der fabrik chef hatte nun
das sagen da wollte nicht jeder
mitmachen und das aus gutem grund
überall auf dem balkan kam es zu unruhen
wegen unzureichender arbeiterrechte
den anfang machte belgrad weil hier die
industrialisierung am schnellsten voran
schritt die auseinandersetzungen waren
ein vorgeschmack auf das was im rest des
landes folgen sollte
wenn es ein gefälle zwischen arm und
reich gibt wenn die einen mehr verdienen
als die anderen entstehen spannungen
serbien war da keine ausnahme
[Musik]
im februar 1907 spitzt sich die lage der
arbeiter in der zucker raffinerie weiter
zu
die aufzeichnungen sind uneindeutig
offenbar hielten sich die deutschen
fabrik eigentümer nicht an die
abmachungen bezüglich der
arbeitsbedingungen und löhne eine
abordnung der belegschaft stellte der
werksleitung ein ultimatum haltet euch
an die abmachungen oder wir streiten
unglücklicherweise sollte das ganze in
einer tragödie enden
die kampflinien sind gezogen weder die
eigentümer noch die 400 strahlt bereiten
arbeiter wollen nachgeben
die arbeiter besetzten die fabrik sie
legten die arbeit nieder
daraufhin rückte die polizei an es gab
streikposten nach mehrtägigen
verhandlungen wurde der streit
schließlich mit waffengewalt
niedergeschlagen
am 14 märz nach 18 tagen pattsituation
kommt das zu gewalttätigen
auseinandersetzungen
die streikposten hatten sich mit
metallstangen und eisen nägeln bewaffnet
einige hatten sogar messer und pistolen
schüsse fielen
sie versuchten die streikführer
festzunehmen alles war sehr dramatisch
das waren polizisten soldaten familien
mit kindern das ganze nahm ein blutiges
ende
vier arbeiter kommen ums leben die
eigentümer werden schließlich
verpflichtet die bedingungen in den
fabriken zu verbessern aber schon bald
zeigt sich dass sie nicht beabsichtigen
ihr wort zu halten
der streit endete mit einer niederlage
schaffte aber einen wichtigen
präzedenzfall
das war die geburtsstunde der
sozialistischen bewegung in serbien und
der kampf ging noch jahrzehntelang
weiter
die raffinerie hat die
auseinandersetzungen unbeschadet
überstanden aber dann kamen zwei
weltkriege und titus regime serbien hat
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert viel
durchgemacht
im lauf der jahrzehnte wird die
raffinerie mehrfach zerstört und wieder
aufgebaut
an der fabrik lässt sich die
ereignisreiche geschichte serbiens
ablesen
1983 wird sie geschlossen
[Musik]
aber damit hat das gelände noch nicht
ausgedient ein paar jahre später wird es
zu event location für kunst und theater
bisher ist hat die neuausrichtung
mitgestaltet
wir hatten hier ein freies theater
komplett ohne förderung dann
organisierten wir rave partys
viele angesagte leute kamen her goldie
aus london david guetta junior jack bob
sinclar stars die sonst bei mtv zu sehen
waren wir feierten riesen partys mit 34
5000 leuten
und es sieht so aus als ob die tage der
fabrik nach lange nicht gezählt sind den
gebäuden soll neues leben eingehaucht
werden
die stadt hat endlich eine umwandlung in
ein kulturzentrum zugestimmt und genau
das passiert hier gerade darüber sind
wir sehr glücklich
[Musik]
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen
und verlassen manche ruinen erinnern an
dunkle zeiten andere waren einst
leuchtende beispiele für technologischen
fortschritt und hoffnung stille zeugen
vom erfindungsreichtum
unternehmungsgeist und tatendrang
[Musik]